nous allons rester dans le sport à
présent avec une soirée de gala qui
s'est tenue au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux précisément un an
après le lancement des travaux
dirigeants et membre de l'équipe de
France rendait visite ce mardi alors
futur quartier d'entraînement et ils se
sont rendus sur le site qui ouvrira fin
2013 Anthony reychia a rencontré le
vice-champion olympique de vitesse
Grégory et Baugé bon moi je me satisfais
jamais de ce que j'ai donc
ces points soulagement en tout cas voilà
ça ça nous fait prendre conscience que
au dessus de notre coach au-dessus de
au-dessus de la Fédération des gens qui
qui ont pris conscience qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait bouger les choses en tout
cas dans le domaine du sport avec un
outil comme ça bien sûr il y en aura
d'autres aussi il y aura d'autres
d'autres infrastructures comme comme à
Saint-Quentin mais bien sûr c'est c'est
tout bonus pour nous l'équipe de France
que ça soit la piste le BM existe aussi
mais dans mon domaine on avait besoin de
ça on a eu besoin de ça et comme j'ai
dit l'objectif pour nous c'est les choix
du monde et surtout les Jeux Olympiques
donc voilà en tout cas on sera pas
on sera pas des enfin on sera dans le
mieux pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
prétendre de belles médailles il y aura
pas de nouveau bouger il y aura pas de
nouveau sirop il y aura d'autres
nouvelles personnes voilà
en tout cas je l'espère en tout cas
j'espère un outil comme ça dans dans
dans
la région parisienne ça peut qu'à
attirer attirer des jeunes autre athlète
présent justement à Saint-Quentin on
Yvelines Kevin sirop lui aussi apprécie
ce futur complexe la piste fera 250
mètres de long sur 8 mètres de large
nous venons de finir la visite du
chantier du vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à mes côtés
Kevin Siro membre de l'équipe de France
cycliste sur piste bonsoir bonsoir alors
premier érection qu'est-ce que ça fait
de voir ce chantier qui évolue plutôt
bien et vite oui bah ça fait plaisir
c'est sûr que d'avoir une structure
comme ça en France on en a pas beaucoup
et même je vais dire très peu donc c'est
bien d'avoir une piste qui se construit
j'ai vu aussi ce pour la fin 2013 donc
c'est très proche on va pouvoir au moins
investir un peu plus de moyens j'espère
sur sur la piste pour les prochains jeux
olympiques oui l'objectif c'est les JO
de 2016 avec cette structure qui va être
un peu le Clairefontaine du football
vous avez tous cette réunit ici au final
dans un an oui oui je pense que
concrètement tout le monde sera ici tous
les centres d'entraînement de cyclisme
seront là et j'espère au moins comme ça
qu'il y aura une bonne entente
la fin de la fédération et au niveau du
timing de l'entraînement parce qu'on
sait que bah il y a l'INSEP et
évidemment mais là ça sera peut-être
plus facile vous serez plus opérationnel
avec Grégory Baugé et les autres
compères de l'équipe non oui en ce
moment il y a encore entre guillemets
deux pôles
en France de sprint c'est-à-dire donc à
l'INSEP et l'autre à Paris et c'est vrai
que moi qui faisait partie aussi de la
vitesse par équipe avec Grégory Baugé et
Michel Dalida pardon c'est pas évident
de s'entraîner pour la vitesse par
équipe tout le temps on se voit rarement
que ce soit surtout sur les stages et
les championnats du monde donc ça sera
plus pratique pour préparer et atteindre
cette médaille d'or qui nous manque
par rapport à cette médaille d'or donc
avant d'arriver à la médaille d'or il
faut bien être formé là ça va être aussi
sûrement un centre de détection il va y
avoir des nouveaux sirop peut-être qui
vont arriver à 50 ans en Yvelines
j'espère au moins que même si on n'est
pas très vieux qui est une suite qui
arrive derrière que le cyclisme soit pas
tombé dans vos oubliettes et que ça
continue avec autant de médailles et
même plus j'espère comme on a un
palmarès aussi grand étant jeune ça vous
a manqué un peu une structure justement
comme ça aussi impressionnante bah pas
vraiment en fait parce que bon étant au
pôle de hier le climat s'y prêtait un
peu plus en a une piste semi-couverte
quand même et puis on a des
infrastructures assez évoluées mais bon
c'est vrai que il y aura beaucoup plus
de choses et beaucoup plus de matériel
pour travailler ici merci Kevin Sirault
pour ces quelques réponses